hello everyone so this is my first
tutorial and also first time here thank
you
and so this was a little experiment that
I made and so the idea is that we're
gonna like a couple months ago in the
tutorial
they used snake as an example and I was
while I was playing I noticed that some
really funny situations appear on on
snake such as like apple right in front
of the snake or or things like that
and at that time I thought about maybe
we can use some regression model or
something to to do this much better than
than this and so as you can see here
like a lot of examples like this would
happen and so and and so and so after
having situation effort to me couple
times I thought about a way of choosing
the location of the Apple in a sort of a
smarter way and I wanted this model take
into account the snake state or position
or direction to be able to predict the
next location of the Apple and this way
we could avoid situations like like this
one here and also we can actually
compare scores between players and
things like that because they are not
affected by this random variable that is
where is the Apple gonna be next and so
but we have some problems because this
is not a conventional regression problem
this one says not really a ground true
for the Apple
several places that could be a good
place to put this Apple and so once that
some apples might have a good location
and some others might not we need a way
to to be able to tell what are the good
locations or not and why good location I
mean that the Apple was put in a place
in which the player has to do some moves
and not just let the snake keep going
straight and so for this we need to find
a way to score each individual Apple
like I was saying and then we want to
use this score to select what were the
best placements of the Apple so to get
this score we're going to create several
metrics to be able to of that to
evaluate the quality of a placement and
so and so we have to think these metrics
in a way that will allow you allow us to
be able to distinguish situations like
the one here two situations that force
the player to take an action and so
after selecting this what are the best
plays and not we are going to to use
this to use this data but there's still
a problem which is like like I was
saying for each snake state each
observation is not necessarily unique
right so there are might be several good
places to put an apple and so for this
we need to generate some more Apple
locations and this will also allow us to
besides having more data to train our
model we can also have some implies some
randomness to to to the final model
which we also want because we don't want
it to always act the same
when the snake is in the same position
and so after this after having a data
set to train in I'm just going to go
through some difficulties and problems
that I found doing cross validation
training tests are mobile and so this is
gonna basically the tutorial is gonna
have two parts so the first part where
we're gonna create a game law the first
part where you're going to create a game
log where we can while playing we can
actually have a CSV or TSV in this case
for with all of our placements so we're
data where the Apple was placed and what
was the snake state at that point and so
for for this first part I had to pick a
game a implementation of snake and I'm
sorry for the the code of this the game
I picked is not the most clean one but
it was the only implementation I found
that that was actually playable and not
just a really simple synonym and so for
this first part where we where we gonna
create a game log this game log is going
to be a file where we write all the
Apple locations in the snake State when
the Apple is placed but because we have
to find a way of finding these we have
to find a way of measuring what is the
quality of our Apple some of the metrics
we are going to use we need to calculate
them during the game and so this was one
of the problems I found with while doing
this
and and so this the the problem is that
like so when we are for each Apple that
the snake catches we need to save what
was the snake position when the Apple
was placed in the inter screen and then
that snake is going to move to catch
this album and as it moves we we want to
save this next position and then wait
for the player to catch the Apple and
while is trying to get the Apple we're
gonna measure these metrics and so we
have to save the snake state at this
point and then when it catches the Apple
then we will save this state and so for
this game walk I end up using a just a
TSV file because it's much easier to
just dump lists which include snake
position in an apple position and all of
that because of the calmness into a file
and so this sorry and so these two these
two time seconds in moves to Apple were
the two metrics that I did I thought
about two to measure doing game play and
I will talk a bit more about them later
and so for this first part I'm gonna go
through the game and some just to show
you some difficulties that I have in
table did I end up sewing sorry and so
this is our game like I said I mean I'm
sorry the code is not
the cleanest I did summer factoring with
steel and it's not the best one and so
the idea here and so we start the game
we do all these units which most of it
it's it's game related things and so
here I created these variables to save
the snake state when we catch the Apple
and then while the playing is trying to
catch that Apple we're gonna measure the
time it's taking it to catch the Apple
and measure how many moves you had to do
and once he catches that Apple then we
will save these positions into a file
and so the things I choose to save about
the snake it was just pretty simple
things just the position direction in
the score at that point and then we are
going to use this these variables later
for for features and training our models
and all of them and so this is this the
normal loop of the game so here we're
basically looping for each frame of the
game here just like some checking
collisions with the snake with the walls
and with the snake itself and so here
when the snake catches the Apple was
where I add most of the most of the work
and so once the game starts let me
actually just show you the game for okay
so then this is the game it's a pretty
simple game just so that you can see it
um and so here
here the idea is that so once the game
starts as you could see he waits for the
for the player to press the first key to
then start to to actually do the game
start the game and so here we're we're
detecting all the key presses events so
here is where once the the player
presses the first key which is when the
first Apple is placed
we're gonna at that point we don't know
what is a snake direction because the
key no key was pressed the end and so
for the first Apple in the game we're
gonna say that the direction of the
snake was zero zero and then we're gonna
write that event to our file and then
the score also which obviously starts as
zero and and we just saved this star
even to a file which includes the snakes
position and the Apple the first
placement of the elbow position and then
for every Apple that the the player
catches we we also gonna ride the event
but so as I as I was saying before
because of we wanna measure time and and
moves to the Apple this right event
happens before actually saving the snake
position because this snake position
will only be saved
when the player catches the next one and
so here also when we catch the apply set
the moves to zero and then here just
have +1 to the move whenever a key is
pressed
besides this in the game there are some
confused files we are where you can pick
the screen size if we want to use a
model or not to generate the apples and
the name of our regressor where the file
of the the Pico file and then a file
name with
just the game log with all these events
that I was talking about before okay so
here is just where I actually write the
other of our TSV and and that's pretty
much it um another thing I had to do
here it was actually so loading the
model which I'm just doing here
and then after loading this model I will
use it in the Apple here where I will
actually whenever a new Apple is
generated I can put the features using
the snake positions and interaction in
game score now we'll talk about what
this feature our later and then set the
position of the snake for the predicted
value of our of our model so here and if
I know everyone is following along I
also have a PDF here with the with this
notebook I forgot to mention if you guys
have some problem setting up
environments or things like that after
creating this this log so after creating
this log um we're gonna move to the
second part are you going to use data
from these logs and I we just created
to select the dataset train and test our
models let me just restore this so I
don't know if anyone has any questions
about this first part where I explained
the concept so for this second part
we're going to open we're going to open
our file and so this is just a helper
function that I created
we're aware so here I just opened that
file that we that we created and like I
said I had to use a TSV because of the
commas in the in the list I was having
some problems with it and then after
then we can check all the all the places
in the in the TSV there are lists which
is the Apple position Apple the snake
position the upper position in the snake
direction and we're gonna transform them
back to lists so that we can use them
during our notebook there's also another
field that for other information during
the game and also I ended up converting
this to array because it's easier to do
with numpy and I also weather so this
field time to Apple it's it's basically
how long the player takes to go from one
Apple to the other because you're doing
the game what I'm actually measuring
it's just a timestamp that starts in the
beginning of the game
and it keeps growing as the game goes
and at the at the end of the game I set
this back to 0 so because it's
increasing I have to subtract the
previous column with a with a with a
next column to get this last time to a
poor volume and so here I just do a
shift in the column and get this this
time to Apple there we can use later to
measure out with our apples work and so
going back to to the notebook oops okay
so here I'm just displaying this all of
these fields to make sure that our
conversions all works and everything and
so here we have the data from the game
that I was talking about and so here we
started by a status so when the game
starts we write the first row with the
time at zero like I was saying and then
this time keeps increasing as as we go
through the game and as the snake
catches apples and so here we we
basically so we have the score of the
sniper here the moves it take you to go
to their pond and then the Apple
position there was placed at that stage
and this is a snake position which we
can see it's an array with more than one
more than one position because it's a
position per block of the snake
and this is the snake direction so in
the all of these positions and
directions the the X's is is as it is
iam so we have the y axis going inverted
compared to the to the normal
representation
Naxos and that's why I plotted it this
way to be able to have the same
reference as I did in the game okay so
here um I also created a helper method
which is called plot snake which it's
basically the function that I did of all
of these images with and so this helper
function can end up being quite useful
because it allowed me to do like quick
debugging allow me to to watch several
placements of the Apple at the same time
and also help me to do simple debugging
and experimenting with the types of
scenarios that that I have for features
for for all of those things and so for
this case for the visualization and also
to help during the debugging phases I
added this previous Apple position where
so we can see what was the Apple that
the snake is catching and also we could
see what is the the next Apple that the
snake has to use and so here we can see
some examples of the snake and so the
the numbers are the so this is the first
Apple that the snake catches as you can
see because the snake is close to it and
then the next one is here so this is the
this zero one it's the previous a
position that I'm that I'm setting here
the also this so the there's a square
that is the dark green this square is
supposed to to be the snake's mouth and
just as a point of reference
um and so as I said now that we have a
data set with all of these Apple
placements the idea is to think about
metrics that allow us to measure the
quality of each Apple location but these
metrics have to take into account the
snakes state which by snake state I mean
it's the snakes direction in position
and so these metrics are like a little
little bit not so easy to think about
because it's hard to find a metric then
that defines this in a good way and so
what I end up doing you was to create
several metrics and as we'll see
depending on how we wait this matrix or
or how we out which metrics we use this
will influence how our apples will be
placed as a mixin and so when designing
this metrics that take into account the
metrics that works better so I tweeted
further the models that work the better
the sorry okay so and when think about
this metric that think about that they
have to be simple because I tried some
harder things in Indian the model just
couldn't figure out those those
connections those relations between the
snake state and what was the different
Apple position and so the metrics that
that I end up implementing he was as I
was saying so the time to Apple that
this time to Apple has to be measure
doing during the game right so it's the
time that basically takes for this night
to go from one Apple to the other
in the point of this metric who was that
basically the longer it takes to get to
an apple the harder for the player he
was or the more action the player that
to take and this is not always
necessarily true there's as I noticed
but as the grain keeps as the game as
the snake keeps growing we we see that
parts of the body of the snake get in
the way of the app on and so you have to
sort of like go around the snake itself
and it's these particular observations
of placing the Apple that that we are
interested about in for this particular
metric and so then also far about the
moves to Apple which it's basically how
many moves it took the player to to get
to the to the next Apple and this is a
pretty simple metric so basically the
more moves you have to do the harder it
was and and therefore there was a better
Apple then then some other Apple then to
class time besides that also use the
Apple distance so it's basically the
distance between the snake's mouth in
the air palm and this is actually one of
the first matrix that I thought about
and the idea of this matrix is to propel
an eye to penalise or apples that were
too close to the snake even though that
that's not necessarily always true that
apples are close to the snake might be
there but the idea was then other
metrics would detect them and so that's
why I end up doing all of these metrics
another metric that I used was the angle
between the snakes direction in the
Apple so the higher this angle is
basically so as we can see here if the
snake is going this way and if an apple
is at this end
here it means that you will have to turn
to actually get to this happen and so
the idea was to try to also identify
these situations with with this metric
here and so um after that I this metric
didn't work as well but I ended up
leaving it here also so the idea was
that the number of times that so if we
look at a straight line from the the
snake's mouth to the Apple the idea was
that if you have an intersection between
the snake and the Apple so in this case
here the snake's body it means that you
can go directly to this happen and
therefore it means that you can go you
have to go around this the the snake
itself to try to to get to that Apple
[Music]
okay so these were the five metrics that
I use Indian um and so here we're gonna
calculate these metrics and so they
happen here in the end of our any other
of our data frame and so next I'm gonna
just walk you through our implemented
these metrics okay so this was a
function that I was running in a
notebook and so here I start by getting
the position of the of the of the
snake's mouth and then because I will
use that in in several metrics and so
the idea here for the Apple distance is
pretty easy I just created a function
that computes distance that I learned
before that Python ate already yes so
a-fightin 2.8 already yes so but and
it's a pretty easy function it just
computes the difference
and then squares it in some Z and then
for them for the angle the way I did it
was that I first off calculated the
angle between the snake mouth and so
thus the snake mouth and the x-axis so
basically think about like a vector then
just as X that's 0 and then as you go
around you get from 0 to 360 in in this
angle and so after having this angle I
calculated the angle between the F in
the Apple which here is represented by
this vector here and then after then I
subtract these two angles to get the
final angle here I get to divide to get
the module the the rest of the division
to to normalize it from 0 to 360 and so
for this this case here what I'm doing
is that I basically normalizing the
angle so in this case here we're not
interested in the side of the angle so I
don't care if it's to this side or to
that side I'm just interesting about the
absolute value of this angle so if this
angle here if the Apple was here this
angle would be the maximum value for
this measure so after that we calculated
the number of intersections with Smike
and for that I use this function here
that I also created there
uses Shapley to basically create the
snake create a line so create this line
here between the snake's mouth and the
Apple and then another line that is the
snake itself and these two lines it's
it's pretty easy to calculate the
intersection which shape limb on that
just there's just a direct function that
does that and then we get this final
value that it's basically the number of
intersections that we have between the
snake in their pond and so in some cases
this was also this was also a line when
when actually the these two lines so if
this line is aligned with the snakes
this kinetically caption can actually
happen to be a line which in that case I
just I just ignore it because that
didn't really happen a lot of times to
be honest so after that so I also
created another metric that Indian lion
not using which was this one here so
it's it was basically the number of
sides in the Apple that are touching the
snake so if in this case would just be
one because this side here the snake is
in front of it and the idea was to try
to detect cases where the Apple is
placed in the middle of the snake where
we would have three cases of in this
case you would have three sides of the
Apple and that means that the Apple is
placed on top of the snake and you will
make it harder for the player to in the
end get
okay I think as matrix that's all and so
now after calculating them we can see
some cases for this matrix where the
player actually where these types of
plays happened so yeah I try to show the
highest cases for each one of the matrix
where where these metrics are actually
useful and so as you can see here the
time to Apple who works really well for
for cases when the snake is quite big
because that means it will take you a
lot more time to go around the snake and
even though that this case is here the
distance is pretty close for example we
can still see then we can still see that
they're still good placements because
it's a it's a really it's a pretty long
snake and makes it that you have to go
around it to to get this final Apple and
so here it's the number of moves which
don't necessarily doesn't not
necessarily means that it's a good play
but as we can see here it also Queens it
with with a time to weapon for four
phases and the other cases are also this
one is actually not super good but this
is why I end up doing several metrics
and so for the Apple distance I created
more I thought about this metric more
for the beginning of the game where the
snake is not the only really the only
thing that you can do to make charter is
place it away from the player
and so here it's the direction of the
snake and so in this case here we can
see that the Apple was placed here and
this angle that I was talking about is
maximum when you put it on the back of
this name which also makes you f to go
around and so most of these cases are
are cases in which the Apple is directly
behind the player and so here for the
number of intersections as we can see
like some of the cases also good
placements none of them are like
placements they are directly in front of
the snake or or things like that and so
here so as in if you look at the
distribution of these metrics we can see
that everything looks good we have the
distance then as sort of a normal
distribution which makes sense because
we're placing these apples randomly and
then we have moves to Apple which it's
also a pretty good distribution there's
a mistake you from the int and there's
some place here that the player actually
had to take more moves than than most of
the normal cases also the intersections
are as expected so decreasing and
there's no more than two intersections
with the snake also in the direction as
we can see goes from zero 280 because I
don't care about the the side of this
angle so I just care if how what is the
angle like how much
the snake has to go to get this happen
the time is also very similar to the
moves which makes sense also and so now
that we have this matrix that I talked
about the idea is to create a final
score with all these metrics that will
allow us to select the the observations
that we want to use to train and this
score can also be used to compare
performance between different models in
the random process for example to see if
our final our final model will be better
than just placing the random randomly
and so to compute this score
we are basically going to calculate a
weighted average of the metrics that we
define so in this allow us to be able to
pick different weights and to be able to
select if we want behaviors there are
more towards a certain metrics or
towards an other metrics and so one of
the problems that I found here is that
each one of these metrics as completely
different scales as we can see here and
so if we use their value directly we
gonna they basically going to have
different weights right so metrics that
have higher values like angles for
example you can have different
contributions so I decided to for each
one of these metrics ranked them and
then instead of using the the value
directly I bring these metrics and
basically end up with a percentile and
each one of these percentiles are going
to be a weight of and then average and
this way we are able to remove
the influence between metrics and
actually get of the same weight for
metric so to calculate this score I
started so here I displaying the metric
column so that we can see how can we do
our weights and so the idea here like I
was saying because I had to rank them
the idea here is then we start with with
our data frame when we select just the
columns that we will use to score and
then here I basically rank them each one
of them and then and then divided by the
maximum rent to get the final percentile
of that metric as you can see here I
also tried just normalizing him with
minimax but it didn't work as well and
after that we're just gonna average them
with the weights I talked about and then
returned the final data frame with with
the score so here I'm just because later
we're gonna need to know what were the
columns that were used specifically for
that was used specifically for for
scoring and so here I'm just checking if
the weight was different than zero then
we will use this this value later and so
here we can see how these scores are so
as we can see they are from zero to one
which makes sense once we just using
percentiles and we can see that we also
have a good distribution of this course
so now once that we have these scores
we we need to filter we need to use this
course to filter our original data and
then get a final training set so here I
start by creating a test set which we
have to do now because we don't have any
influence from our test set to peak our
scores and so here we can select
different values so the higher the score
is as you can see the less samples we're
gonna have which also makes sense and so
if this goes too low we're just gonna
get a lot of bad apples that won't allow
us to Indian train our model and so
after this after creating our training
set we have to make sure that we have
observations in all the spectrums of the
game score because we do want our model
to just be good when score is higher
than 20 or whatever so for that I just
plot the distribution of our scores and
then as you can see here we have most of
these observe we have arranged in all
the scores which allows our model to
know cases for for all the scores that
we use and so so as I said before we
also need to so once now that we have
already a training training set the idea
here it's - for each state of the snake
we need to generate more than one just
one case just one Apple because first
off we don't our model to overfit for
those cases
and then in it it's actually what
happens because we there's not just one
case when the Apple is displayed and so
besides that I also because we're doing
all these metrics and all the filtering
and so we don't want to generate apples
that have worst metrics than the
original ones and so here for each next
a we are basically gonna generate try to
generate a number of a number of apples
[Music]
and so here I start by here I'm just
calculating what is the range because
there's cases in which the apple is in a
corner and for those cases we we need to
reduce the range in which we're
generating apples because we don't want
supposed to be out of the screen soon so
here I calculate the limits for X&Y
with this limit so we have a limit of 50
50 by 52 to generate apples around the
original one after this I just stack
both X&Y um after after generating the
the random locations that I will then
add to the original one so here I just
generated a value maximum between minus
50 and 50 and so here we just gonna have
the random positions that we just
created to our original apple position
and then here we're just generating a
data set that has the same snake
position the same direction and
everything but in the end it has one it
has a different Apple and so after that
we are going to compute the matrix for
these apples
and this is where I use the valid
columns that I filtered and that I
calculated above to know how to know
actually what were the metrics they were
used so that I can just filter those
metrics and so here all I do is just see
what are in these new apples data frame
I see what are the for the valid columns
I see which ones are basically highest a
bigger equal to to my original case so
here we're just testing this and as you
can see sometimes we don't even get any
apples sometimes we get so because they
ran them and then I'm filtering the
metrics each column can generate a
different number of apples so after this
so this function will be used later
doing cross-validation in training so in
the in the next in the next section I'm
gonna talk about the features that are
used to to be able to do this and so in
this case because our model has to react
to the snake position in direction we
need features that that reflect this and
so for this we use directly the snake
direction just test them you once we
only have four possible cases which is
left right up and down and then the same
for the snakes direction but for the
snakes position once the size keeps
going as the game progresses and our
feature size there always to be the same
we need to find a way to normalize this
this array of positions to a constant
size and so to do this I basically
consider the line as we can see here the
starts from the Apple starts from the
the end of the snake and goes towards
the end and then we want to normalize
this number of positions at the snake as
in this case it's 11 to only 5 so
considering this line after that I'm
gonna equally sample this line in the
endpoints that I want to reduce the
snake to as we can see here and so we
end up having this this array with
always five positions that describes the
snake beginning in and other points
doing the snake so besides that I just
did quite simple features just like mini
Max and min of the snake location which
Indian didn't help much and so it was
just basically that the most useful
feature was was by far the the line and
also the direction um so here were
calculating our features as you can see
here so because we have x and y
coordinates this makes it this makes it
that we have a position zero and a
position position zero y and X and as I
said the normalized five positions which
when when the snake for example only has
one position and we are only gonna get
all of these fellows are going to be the
same because we just have one position
right and so to calculate the features
to calculate the features I tried to
keep so for these features we have to
declare in the game because we need to
calculate everything during game also
all these t20 we call play during the
game in
and and then I just imported from from
the Jupiter notebook and so I also try
to be careful here doing the features
once they're running inside the game to
not use pandas and just try to use them
PI even though that it's a pretty light
game I tried to be careful with that and
so for these features we have this
function that computes all the features
and so we start by normalizing the
position like I said in 4/4 this case I
end up using just a lean space of numpy
then interpolates the the snakes
position in this line space space and
makes that in the end we just can
enhance endpoints for the position
so when it's one as I said I just
returned those that point five times and
here I also did some position statistics
so this function just receives the list
of functions and computes those
functions and saves them in a list to be
able to use during the game I also used
this function for to to get the damage
for the direction that we need both
doing in play and for our notebook and
so these are just the statistics that I
did just min Max and average but most of
these things are already in the
normalized position so in the end it
wasn't super useful and so after
normalizing the position I
I just get the statistics right I have
the most auxiliar verse to be able to
return the feature names for my notebook
and because I didn't wanna have features
in two places I decided to create
everything here to be able to call it
from both sides and don't have any
problems with with the features and so
after this I do the dummy for for the
direction with this function here which
just checks once we the ones there's
only four directions the direction
vector will always have one of them as
there is zero or both of them will be
zero in when the game is starting which
is this state that is stop and then but
because I end up not using stop because
it means that we just need four and when
we stop none of them is true and so for
features I end up just using this for
these four cases and so after that I
just concatenate all the features and
and return them as an array if we're
calling this function inside the game if
we're calling this function from the
notebook then I have to get all the all
the feature names where I do that here
for the position in the range of the
points you have for the statistics - for
the snake direction with all the dummy
letters also and then I just do a
dictionary with all the feature of Elvis
that we can use in the notebook so after
then um we're gonna try to train our
model with with our features in so here
and doing the only the only problem that
I had it was there
I wanted to use cross-validation but
because we are generating a place there
are there are exactly the same snake
position in where the Apple just changes
and even then the Apple is still close
to the other one so we have to be really
careful in cross validation to not leak
these snake positions from the training
set to the test set and so because of
that I end up using just grid search TV
and from skete learn and I implemented
my own faults and also my own matrix
because this case were trying to predict
two points x and y and ski to learn just
assume is that they're two independent
predictions when they're not because
we're talking about a location so for
this I use the distance between the
points to have the final the final error
the final error for cross-validation and
so here to implement the the folds
manually it's quite easy whisky to learn
you just need a list with the indexes of
each hold and what is the training set
and why is the test basically and so
here's where we're going to use the the
function to generate new apples and so
we start by creating three folds with
with k-fold and then because we want to
make sure that there's no leaking
between tests and train sin we have to
generate the apples only with the Train
only with the train set and for that we
just use the indexes directly to to pass
this to the function that generates more
apples and then we have a final data
frame with all the general apples
and then we have to update the indexes
for our training fold and so this is
what I'm doing next so I just basically
get the size of the training set and
then I will use this size to create a
range that I will add to the training
set and I'm just basically so I'm
basically appending the generated apples
in the end of the of the data set and
then setting the indexes in the training
set for the end of the day design this
takes a little bit to run so after then
um so here I end up using computer
features this way with the apply because
we have to use this function also during
the game so this function has to compute
a line at a time and so I end up just
doing an apply and then stacking all the
arrays of this feature to get my X
training set and also my ground trim and
so as we can see here this matches these
two sizes here so and as you can see
here even though that we are trying six
times for Apple that doesn't mean that
we're gonna get six times more apples we
have about three which makes sense
because all of them are not going to
have the good metrics to to be able to
go for the for the training set and so
after that we pick our aggressor I tried
a couple more than random forests in the
working vest even though that um there's
not a lot of data
and so here for a cross-validation like
I was saying I just created the agreed
with the parameters that I want to test
and I had to make my own score which
estimates on the final a final value but
because the Skip learn sends all of the
predictions at once and this function
only was only computing one point I
ended up just creating a lambda to feed
to the mix scorer and then create a
final score so this greed gets the folds
we created above also gets our scorer
and the model that we want to Train
basically and also the parameters of
course here because so grid search
returns all the all the results in a
very confusing way with all with this
object so I end up creating the nice
visualization just in pandas to be able
to tell how things are going and so that
we can see that it's not a super stable
stable training because our our
parameters are very law and the test set
is not decreasing a lot from premiere to
parameter which probably means we don't
have enough sytem because i would
probably have to play something for
quite a while to ever enough data to to
train here but this was still the
classifier that i got in the best
results win and so after this we're
going to calculate our training error
and so for this we shouldn't use the the
same data said they were use for
cross-validation because we have used we
have used the same sample to generate
apples more than more
because this sample was present in in
different training folds and so here
this is what I'm doing so I basically
generate all the apples again for the
first selected data set that I have and
then and then create a total training
set that is this selector data set plus
my generation data and so here I'm doing
the same thing again calculating my
features in stacking them my Y and then
here our muscle using sample weights
this sample which they reflect directly
the score that I was using because I was
trying to basically make certain plays
more important than others but in the
end the results were didn't doesn't
didn't really help much so I end up
removing it here I'm also setting them
I'm increasing the roomiest images
because this is our final estimator so
just to get a bit more acute so for our
training error finally um we can 89% 89
average distance between predictions
which comparing with our test score from
China validations shows that we're
probably over feeding a little bit and
so which shows once again that we needed
more data to India never been actual
good model and so here we can take a
look at our distributions so and as we
can see the some cases the distance are
actually being quite good but some of
them are actually not that good and the
end result wasn't like super great it
works but it's not um the best you so
here for the features importance so as
you can see the normalized positions of
the snakehead are the most important
ones and also some directions because of
the because of the metric that measures
the the direction compared to the snake
direction and yeah most of the other
features weren't really that important
so here we can see the the snakes plot
with the predictions which is zero is
the original one and the predictions are
r1 and so so here we can see a little
bit that the the Apple the the model
tends to shift our predictions a bit to
the middle here because it's safer and
and the error will be eventually lower
when you which shows that we probably
need more features to try to have a
better result Indian so here so now I'm
just gonna save the model and making
sure that I get the same error and then
I can load it and so now we can actually
use this model to play our game and so
here you can see that because of our
location the model tends to put the the
Apple a lot in the back of the snake
which is an interesting game the reason
for that is that because that's probably
the only feature that the model can peek
- - in the end be able to have a better
performance
so as for testing testing was a was a an
interesting case because some metrics
are calculating doing game and some
others are not so ideally you should be
testing it in the actual game by playing
and then making sure that your metrics
are higher than all of your metrics are
higher than the random process but
because they're really difficult
development because you have to play
every time unit test model I just
created the tests and with the last
games that I created and we that test I
check the metrics that don't depend on
the game and just use those metrics as
my final as my final result and so here
because we're this test that he also
doesn't make sense to use the same
metric we're using in cross-validation
because here what we actually want to
compare is not how close to the final
Apple you were but more how how good the
Apple is so compared to the metrics and
not comparing to the random process that
we were doing before
like we did win cross-validation and so
for this I'm just computing the features
for my test set and then computing the
matrix instead of the distance this time
and so here we can see the metrics for
our product for our predictions and here
we can see the metrics origionally and
so we have moves to Apple in time to
Apple which should be the same because
we didn't actual plane and then we have
the distance and these few ones that are
a little bit higher in our predictions
compared to to the previous one and so
just as a final challenge I'd like to
I'm not sure if we still have time for
this and I'd like you for you to try to
actual play and then get some
observations and then try to try to get
your own model but probably because you
only have a hundred plays you'll be even
harder to turn your model so maybe if
you decrease the number if you increase
the number of tries and in the quiz your
score function you can actually get a
model that the does something again um
and that's it thank you and I she
[Music]